[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8
j'espère que le week-end a été bon et
comme d'habitude on redémarre la semaine
sur TV 78 avec de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie tout de
suite là le programme le sommaire de ce
lundi 3 avril et jusqu'à samedi c'est la
septième semaine olympique et
paralympique le but promouvoir la
pratique sportive chez les jeunes à
désormais 480 jours de Paris 2024 cette
année l'événement a pour thème
l'inclusion c'est pourquoi 50 ans en
Yvelines organisent des rencontres et
activités sportives entre jeunes et
résidents des potes comme cet après-midi
au Vélodrome national nous en parlons
avec Maxime Lucas de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à quelques
jours de Pâques la Garde Républicaine
organise une chasse aux œufs solidaire
elle va ouvrir à sa caserne de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ce mercredi à
l'association imagine fort Margaux pour
offrir un moment agréable à des enfants
atteints par un cancer c'est la première
cause de mortalité par maladie chez les
enfants et les adolescents en France
invités Maxime rock responsable
communication d'Imagine fort Margaux
et puis comme chaque lundi tour
d'horizon des principaux résultats
sportifs du week-end les rugbymen de
Versailles qualifiés pour les barrages
de Fédérale 2 après leur victoire hier
contre le retour également sur la
quatrième édition de la diagonale des
Yvelines sans km de trail entre
breuil-bois-haubert et Rochefort en
Yvelines et tout ça ce sera avec vous
Michael ennemie de bonsoir bonsoir mon
avis ce sport de la rédaction de TV 78
on parlera aussi de foutus dans cette
partie sport on parlera des Templiers
d'élancourts ils sont pas au mieux en ce
moment dans le championnat de deuxième
division casque d'or on va les recevoir
dans quelques instants ils sont dernier
mais ils espèrent évidemment finir le
plus haut possible dans cette division
mais ce sera tout à l'heure dans le 7 8
à vos côtés Céline Charles bonsoir avec
vous dans un instant à toutes les
informations à retenir de ce jour de ce
lundi 3 avril on va bien sûr parler de
Paris 2024 puisque c'est le début de la
semaine olympique et paralympique des
événements partout dans les Yvelines et
notamment à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
cet après-midi au Vélodrome des élèves
aux côtés de personnes âgées en EHPAD
qui sont résidents en EHPAD pour une et
visite et aussi des Olympiades bonsoir
Maxime Lucas bonsoir de l'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-y vous êtes chargé
de la de promotion de la vie sportive
alors cet événement marqué le début de
la semaine olympique sur le territoire
ça s'est bien déroulé cet après-midi
très bien déroulé on était très content
on a pu accueillir au Vélodrome national
une classe qui nous venait de Coignières
25 enfants et 25 personnes un peu moins
jeunes qui venait pour la plupart d'une
résidence autonome qui est située à
Trappes mais aussi des habitants de
Trappes qui ont accompagné et qui ont
l'habitude de faire ces sorties avec la
résidence autonome non l'occasion de
revenir sur cet événement et de cette
semaine qui s'ouvre à 50 ans en Yvelines
une semaine olympique et paralympique
dédié cette année à l'inclusion enfin
dans le 7 8 on va se plonger dans les
archives celle des Yvelines bien sûr les
archives départementales viennent de
renforcer leur routine d'interrogation
de la presse locale ancienne plus de 220
000 pages sont accessibles en ligne
couvrant les années 1819 à 1969 pour en
parler romain du gars bonsoir chef du
service public des Archives
départementales des Yvelines déjà
peut-être quelques mots de présentation
des Archives départementales elles sont
installées à Montigny-le-Bretonneux quel
est l'étendue des des fonds dont vous
avez à disposition alors les archives
départementales sont une vieille
institution puisqu'elles ont été créées
en 1796 dans la foulée de la création
des départements on a créé dans chaque
département un centre en capacité
d'accueillir les archives dans un
premier temps d'anciens régime des
institutions qui ont été
séquestrées les séquestres
révolutionnaires qui constituent le
noyau des Archives départementales et on
continue à accueillir les archives de
l'ensemble des administrations qui ont
leur siège dans le département des
Yvelines que ce soit des services de
l'État les archives des notaires du
conseil départemental mais aussi parfois
des archives de deux particules des
associations qui peuvent être donnés aux
archives départementales des ressources
donc sur place mais aussi numérisées
c'est ça tout à fait c'est-à-dire que on
conserve actuellement 32 km d'archives
et parmi ces 32 km à peu près
ça représente ce qu'on a pu numériser
jusqu'à présent représente 6 millions de
vues donc c'est parfois des documents
qui représentent plusieurs images mais
en tout cas il y a 6 millions de
d'images consultables en ligne sur le
site Internet des Archives
départementales on parle de tous ces
sujets tout à l'heure dans le 7 8 mais
avant cela coup d'oeil à la météo
du soleil et un ciel dégagé au menu de
votre journée de mardi dans les Yvelines
ça devrait se poursuivre pendant une
bonne partie de la semaine le matin les
températures sont fraîches il fera 3
degrés dans le secteur de Versailles et
Mantes-la-Jolie de degrés vers ou dans
et Rambouillet dans l'après-midi malgré
le soleil le thermomètre ne montra pas
bien haut comptait 10 degrés dans toute
la moitié nord des Yvelines onces de
gras Rambouillet ce mardi 4 avril c'est
la Saint Isidore on fait le point tout
de suite sur les informations du jour
dans les Yvelines
et on commence donc ces lignes par cette
information le début de la semaine
olympique et paralympique au-delà de 50
ans Yvelines dont on va parler dans un
instant la mobilisation étant
rendez-vous sur tout le territoire oui
beaucoup d'événements sont organisés
dans les Yvelines et la ville de
Fontenay-le-Fleury a ouvert le bal ce
samedi 1er avril avec les olympidés au
programme de la journée plusieurs
rendez-vous avec des athlètes de haut
niveau mais aussi la découverte d'une
quinzaine de disciplines olympiques et
paralympique la rencontre avec des
professionnels de santé ou encore des
activités autour du théâtre donc ça
c'était samedi aujourd'hui l'UNSS
l'Union nationale des du sport scolaire
c'est aussi mobilisé et c'était au
complexe sportif montboron de Versailles
que la fédération sportive a organisé sa
première journée sport partagée 300
collégiens et lycéens de Versailles
ainsi que des jeunes inscrits en
établissement spécialisé des Yvelines
ont découvert et pratiqué 9 activités
par un sportif ils ont également pu
rencontrer des champions handisport
écoutés on a dû voler assis du basket
fauteuil de la bottecia du goal ball de
l'escalade en aveugle on est le sport
scolaire du second degré dans les
Yvelines et partout en France et donc
par ce biais là on se sent
l'envie et puis la motivation pour
embarquer tous les élèves vers les Jeux
Olympiques leur faire connaître ses
épreuves qui auront lieu très proche de
chez eux puisque même à Versailles on
aura des épreuves on aura la chance dans
les Yvelines d'avoir des épreuves
olympiques et donc on cherche à faire
connaître à la population et qu'il se
sentent concernés
et même chose pour le centre aqualudique
Castalia de morpa qui va accueillir
toute la semaine des classes de
maternelle et primaires du territoire
pour découvrir des handisports comme la
nage à l'aveugle ou la nage avec un
membre bloqué les enfants ont pu
notamment être accompagnés cet
après-midi par Cécile saboureaux para
triathlète 5 continents
de Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
organisera jeudi 6 avril des ateliers
démonstration du judo inclusif et
vendredi 7 avril un spectacle de danse
elle aussi inclusive le tout est ouvert
au public un ouvrier de la nouvelle
itinéraire cyclable cyclable je vais y
arriver que l'on peut tarpenter dans les
Yvelines
elle se situe sur la RD 912 entre les
communes de Villiers-Saint-Frédéric le
nofle-le-vieux mère et galluy et elle
s'étend sur 6,5 km sur la plupart du
tronçon il s'agit d'une piste cyclable
unidirectionnelle de part et d'autre de
la route à terme cette aménagement a
pour but de créer une liaison cyclable
de 22 km permettant de relier la queue
les Yvelines à Plaisir écoutez c'est une
satisfaction parce que ce sont des des
chantiers relativement longs parce que
c'est assez compliqué puisqu'il faut
faire cohabiter la circulation
automobile faire cohabiter avec les
piétons donc les cyclistes puisque c'est
un aménagement de pistes cyclables donc
c'est c'est toujours un peu délicant en
tout cas le département montre une
grande expertise avec ses services et
puis mets un œuvre des moyens
conséquents rendez-vous compte près de 3
millions d'euros pour ces aménagements
cyclables sur 6 km et demi c'est
vraiment pas rien
donc c'est un grand sujet de
satisfaction
dans l'actualité du jour Céline
également cet accident mortel sur
l'autoroute A13 oui c'est ce matin qui a
eu lieu ce grave accident sur
l'autoroute près de Mantes-la-Jolie
l'automobiliste de 39 ans est tombé en
panne et n'a pas eu le temps de se
rabattre sur la bande d'arrêt d'urgence
il a été percuté de plein fouet par un
autre véhicule et décédé sur place ce
secteur de la 13 et d'ailleurs
particulièrement accidentogène les
services d'intervention de la Société
des autoroutes de Paris Normandie ont
réalisé près de 500 interventions en
2022 la visite ministérielle du côté de
la maison Elsa Triolet Aragon à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines avec la venue
sur place de Rima Abdul Malak ministre
de la Culture s'y est rendu ce dimanche
2 avril elle était accompagnée d'Aurore
Bergé député de la dixième
circonscription des Yvelines et de la
camélise l'académicien français et
président de l'association qui gère la
maison Elsa Triolet Aragon
erena Rima abdull Malak a pu découvrir
ce lieu ouvert depuis 1994 et dans
lequel a vécu le couple d'écrivain on
termine avec un chiffre 73 73 m3 de
fournitures scolaires vont être vous
voyez dans un lycée sénégalais vers un
lycée sénégalais et le tout grâce à une
association elle est en courtoise tout à
fait Grégory il s'agit de l'association
container sans frontières elle a
démarché collège et lycée du temps pour
réunir du matériel scolaire à
destination du Sénégal au total 73
mètres cubes de matériel informatique
mobilier ou encore livre ont été
récoltés par plusieurs établissements on
retrouve par exemple le lycée Descartes
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et le lycée
franco-allemand de Buc c'est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui que c'est élancé Delancourt
le conteneur à destination du lycée
sénégalais merci Céline et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une information
d'une actualité qui vous a marqué près
de chez vous et n'hésitez pas à le dire
en utilisant sur les réseaux sociaux le
hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
vous l'avez entendu dans les
informations du jour c'est la septième
semaine olympique et paralympique
partout en France et notamment à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans très
exactement
480 jours l'agglomération accueillera
quelques-unes des épreuves des JO de
Paris 2024 avec des sites olympiques la
colline d'Élancourt le golfe nationale
et le vélo drone national qui a en plus
accueilli aujourd'hui ce vélo drone un
premier rendez-vous dans le cadre de la
Semaine Olympique on le disait tout à
l'heure on va en parler avec Maxime
Lucas qui a changé de promotion de la
vie sportive à 50 ans en Yvelines déjà
peut-être un petit tour de table et ce
qui est un engouement particulier de
votre part j'imagine le journaliste de
sport que vous êtes nickel avec cette
échange olympique qui arrive on est à
480 jours désormais de cet échéance
olympique on se dit surtout que ça
arrive ça va arriver très vite il reste
peu de temps d'ici les Jeux Olympiques
et ça va monter en puissance il va avoir
des tests events qui vont être organisés
sur le territoire je crois que en
septembre il y aura notamment sur la
colline d'Élancourt un test Steven donc
comment on attend ça avec impatience
Céline
un événement qui met en valeur en plus
le territoire moi c'est surtout
l'équitation qui me qui me donne envie
romain du gars un regard vers le passé
avec les archives départementales
forcément un regard vers le futur aussi
avec cette échéance olympique qui arrive
tout près tout proche des archives des
Archives départementales tout à fait et
justement enfin on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mais on développe on a
développé une application de d'enquête
géolocalisée et
en tant que tel c'est une possibilité
d'itinérance sur le territoire donc
c'est quelque part un parcours sportif
qu'on proposera enfin voilà les archives
départementales vont se mobiliser
également dans le cadre des JO donc pour
faire monter l'engouement cette semaine
olympique et paralympique 7e édition
Maxime Lucas quel est l'objectif c'est
justement de sensibiliser aux valeurs de
l'olympisme c'est ça alors les journées
olympiques enfin la Semaine Olympique et
paralympique c'est c'est organisé par
Paris 2024 et l'éducation nationale avec
comme premier objectif de mettre plus de
sport dans le quotidien des des enfants
et aussi de pouvoir leur transmettre
l'engouement qui va y avoir au niveau
des des Jeux Olympiques c'est les plus
jeunes sont très éloignés de ça et ne
prennent pas encore plein de conscience
de ce qui va se passer chez eux en 2024
surtout pour des jeunes habitants de
l'agglomération et c'est pour ça que 50
ans Yvelines mais mais les moyens pour
mettre en place des actions dans le
cadre de cette semaine olympique
le premier objectif pour 50 ans de
Linkedin c'est de que ces enfants
s'assent s'approprient les les jeux qui
vont se dérouler chez eux cette
génération 2024 qu'elle soit au fait que
il y a des JO avaient bien entendu dans
dans un peu plus d'un an maintenant en
France alors la thématique cette année
je disais tout à l'heure c'est
l'inclusion donc sensibiliser les jeunes
mais on va y associer aussi les aînés
les seniors des EHPAD de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines vous allez profiter de cette
semaine à 50 en ligne pour organiser des
rencontres justement entre jeunes et
personnes âgées du territoire alors
c'était le cas d'ailleurs cet après-midi
au Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines avec un rendez-vous qui s'est
mieux regarder ces quelques réactions
collectées sur place par Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude il a pu justement collecter
quelques réactions de participants des
jeunes et des seniors associés pour cet
événement par exemple en vacances j'ai
toujours plein et bien plein avec moi et
bien souvent il y en a qui disent il
n'est pas venu une fois il y a un qui me
dit adieu j'aurais été content que tu
sois mon grand-père parce que j'amuse
tout le monde je suis très dynamique
voilà
parce que j'ai quand même eu besoin de
lui pour tenir un peu je pense que c'est
la nouvelle méthode depuis quelques
temps
de mettre des personnes
des seniors avec la nouvelle génération
pour qu'il s'apprenne aussi bien de nos
connaissances que l'inverse de leur
facilité de pouvoir bouger ça nous
rajeunit c'est très bien c'est très bien
je te présente ma petite camomille
mais c'était mieux
le coup de sourire cet après-midi au
vélo de route nationale vous l'avez dit
sensibiliser les jeunes mais là on y
associe des personnes âgées pourquoi ce
choix pour pour l'agglomération c'est
sous cet angle qu'on a souhaité de
traiter d'inclusion
et c'est pas le seul angle sur lequel on
va se baser cette semaine
je sais pas si on va revenir sur le
programme des actions mais il était
important pour nous d'associer les moins
jeunes à ces actions et travailler avec
cette résidence autonome ou les EHPAD
avec lesquels on va travailler à la fin
de la semaine pour montrer que le sport
voilà est un super lien entre des jeunes
des personnes plus âgées
on a vu voilà des gens qui ne se
seraient pas forcément connus autre parc
que cet après-midi voilà elles étaient
rassemblement audio il y avait un jeune
et une personne âgée c'est ça c'est ça
alors sur l'après-midi ils ont commencé
par visiter le vélo Drôme pour la
plupart c'était la première fois qui
rentrait dans le dans le vélo drone ou
alors ils étaient venus se faire
vacciner mais là ils ont vraiment pu
découvrir le vélo drone découvrir on
leur a présenté ce qui était le cyclisme
sur piste un vélo de cyclisme sur piste
et ensuite il y avait oui tout un
atelier de sportifs où ça se faisait en
binôme avec un élève de cette classe de
Coignières et une personne âgée et
ensuite ils ont terminé par par une
visite du Stadium BMX ou ils ont pu
assister à un entraînement de l'équipe
de France mais parce que sur ce site du
Vélodrome on rappelle les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste et on est juste à
côté du Stadium de BMX où se dérouleront
bien sûr ces épreuves olympiques de BMX
ça ne va pas s'arrêter là semaine il y a
tout un programme qui est qui sera
déployé par 50 en Yvelines c'est ça
c'est une semaine où on va pas arrêter
on a décidé d'avoir des actions sur
toute la semaine et surtout les jours
jusqu'à vendredi demain on sera au golf
national avec en s'association avec le
Golf National et la Fédération Française
de Golf et cette fois-ci le l'inclusion
sera traité sous l'angle de du paragole
avec la présence d'Aurélien Lacour qui
est para golfeur de très très haut
niveau et il y aura également des des
ateliers de golf ou les enfants seront
mis en situation de handicap pour
pouvoir se mettre dans la position de
personne en situation de handicap et par
ce biais-là entraide on traite le
handicap donc finalement différents
points de vue sur la sur l'inclusion
indifférent de manière d'aborder le
sujet c'est ça et on va poursuivre la
semaine ensuite mercredi on sera de
retour au Vélodrome cette fois-ci on est
plus avec des des scolaires de primaire
mais avec des collégiens des lycéens on
s'associe à l'un process et on
présentera l'inclusion sur la thème du
parasyclisme avec la présence du WC de
Sky le club de vélo de d'Élancourt qui
qui a des une section dédiée aux para
cyclistes chez eux et qui présentera
cette discipline
et ensuite je dis et vendredi on se
déplacera dans des EHPAD à chaque fois
avec une classe pour la pression d'une
fresque
il y aura des moments sportifs et une
fresque sur le thème des jeux voilà qui
pourra être laissé après aux EHPAD
Michael vous avez une question
que c'est très bien en tout cas de
mettre en place ce lien
intergénérationnel parce que les JO
c'est vraiment pour tout le monde donc
forcément ça va concerner tout le monde
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines enfin c'était
impressionnant d'avoir les mêmes
réactions sur l'inclinaison de la piste
que soit les enfants ou les personnes
âgées cet après-midi au Vélodrome quand
elles sont arrivées elles ont toutes eu
cet effet waouh de découvrir cette
inclinaison et c'était les mêmes les
mêmes grands yeux face aux entraînements
de l'équipe de France de BMX derrière
donc on voit que le sport est un super
vecteur pour pour parler à plein de gens
de qui sont tous différents
à tout le monde puisque le prochain gros
temps fort aussi en matière de
l'olympisme ce sera la journée olympique
qui va aussi arriver pour
l'agglomération d'habitude ouvert
uniquement au scolaire et cette année
l'ambition c'est l'ouvrir à tout le
monde ouais c'est ça alors la journée
olympique
il y a une date officielle qui a une
date mondiale qui est le 23 juin donc
cette année ça tombe à un vendredi ça se
déroulera au golf national et le
vendredi on le dédie comme d'hab comme
les autres années au scolaires et par
contre on poursuivra le samedi avec les
mêmes partenaires qui sont des
fédérations des ligues et des comités
mais aussi des clubs locaux et là on
invite tout le monde ça sera gratuit
ouvert à tous sans inscription au golf
national et là tout le monde pourra
s'essayer un maximum de sport il sera
possible de faire de l'escalade du rugby
enfin tout ça sur un même site et au
cours d'une même journée et en plus
l'agglomération présentera tout un tas
de d'actions dédiées à l'accueil des
jeux un programme volontaire pour être
volontaire sur les jeux un nouveau site
internet il y aura plein de choses
d'annoncées ce 24 juin redonnez-nous la
date le 24 juin samedi 24 juin au golf
national on voit les précédentes
éditions de cette journée olympique très
très rapidement Michael ce qu'on a et
vous attendez combien de personnes sur
cette journée-là
il y a énormément de monde on sait qu'on
est en capacité d'accueillir plus de 500
personnes en simultanées donc on a pas
de limite de jauge sur la journée l'idée
c'est de sensibiliser le maximum de 50
ninois de famille 50 chinoises au sport
mais aussi de leur parler JO de voir
leur proposer de leur présenter ce qui
va se passer chez eux dans on sera le 24
besoin à j-400 de la première épreuve
accueillie sur Saint-Quentin
Maxime Lucas d'être venu parler de tous
ces sujets en plateau chargé de
promotion de la vie sportive à 50 ans en
Yvelines un petit tour de table est-ce
que vous faites un peu de photos autour
de la table au moins du gars pas du tout
un petit peu mais pas argentique
numérique plutôt argentique Maxime pas
du tout pas du tout du tout non je fais
plus de vidéos du coup de vidéo mais
dans notre dans notre pays je crois que
vous en faites un peu de photographie
Céline et plutôt argentique numérique
j'ai essayé l'argentique mais c'est
quand même beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça demande beaucoup plus de temps ne
serait-ce que pour faire développer sa
pellicule donc ouais plutôt numérique
revient à la mode notamment chez les
jeunes peut-être avez-vous déniché dans
les affaires de vos parents de vos
grands-parents et de vieux appareils
photos qui ne fonctionnent plus et bien
yvelinois Adrien simmeret propose de les
réparer la fonder sa propre entreprise à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Jessie et Willens
de nos confrères et de radio sensation
et parti à sa rencontre je vous Adrien
simmerait cette yvelinois habite à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et a fondé
péloche moi il vous propose de réparer
vos vieux appareils photos argentiques
alors l'argentique ça permet vraiment de
faire des photos qui sont différentes
assez souvent on va le comparer au
numérique pour moi ce sont vraiment deux
façons de faire différentes pour créer
de l'image l'argentique elle a un rendu
qui est très spécifique que à titre
personnel sensible on a un grain déjà
avant que je fasse du numérique j'avais
été sensible à part tout ce qui était
son rendu vraiment du grain qu'on peut
avoir sur certaines pellicules en noir
et blanc que je trouve magnifique
aujourd'hui ça revient ça va faire plus
de 5 6 ans qu'on dit que c'est à la mode
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus à la
mode parce que la mode normalement était
fait mère donc aujourd'hui pour moi
c'est inscrit vraiment comme une
discipline à part entière fait logement
ça pour but du coup de pouvoir proposer
des boîtiers réviser garanties qui vont
pas planter parce qu'il faut savoir que
les boîtiers ils ont en général une
cinquantaine d'années comme une bagnole
il faut les réviser les revu les regrets
etc pour que justement ils puissent
produire de l'image assez souvent ce qui
se passe c'est qu'on va acheter un
boîtier il a pas forcément être
fonctionnel il va avoir des fuites de
lumière et ça nous dégoûte très
facilement la photo il s'engage
également dans un geste éco-responsable
en donnant une seconde vie à des
appareils photos qui ont capturé des
moments familiaux importants je m'engage
dans un geste responsable parce que je
suis vraiment dans la réutilisation le
plus possible d'appareil photo qui ont
déjà marqué en plus l'histoire la
photographie qui sont fonctionnaires
d'autres vont avoir besoin de réparation
et on sait les réparer moi je continue
vraiment à me former régulièrement via
Internet parce qu'on a énormément de
savoir c'est vraiment génial
pour leur donner une seconde vie afin
que des personnes qui souhaitent
apprendre la photographie puisse le
faire avec des boîtiers vraiment
totalement fonctionnel on est vraiment
dans une volonté de déconsommation où
j'essaye le plus possible de reproduire
des pièces là par exemple je viens
d'acheter une imprimante 3D pour pouvoir
recréer les pièces qui ne se font plus
aujourd'hui et là heureusement la
nouvelle technologie comme les
imprimantes 3D et tout ça permet
vraiment de déboucher des appareils une
photo qui était plus réparable et pour
ceux qui veulent se mettre à
l'argentique le site Internet propose
des appareils reconditionnés pourquoi
l'argentique parce que c'est un moyen
qui permet de faire de l'image qui va
vraiment avoir une authenticité on va
avoir un rendu qui est très particulier
qu'on va pas retrouver en numérique je
crois de manière plus large que
l'argentique dans un contexte de
création artistique parce qu'il a des
contraintes comme le dire par rapport au
numérique on peut monter en sensibilité
faire un peu tout et n'importe quoi
l'argentique a des contraintes mais des
contraintes nées la créativité la
l'expérience utilisateur est différente
on va vraiment prendre son temps
réfléchir avant de déclencher parce que
quand même ça coûte cher une photo en
argentique pour la réparation d'un
appareil photo argentique il faudra
compter entre 150 et 200 euros et un
délai d'environ trois semaines prochain
objectif pour Adrien ouvrir sa boutique
sur Paris
la suite du 7 8 avec un nouvel invité en
plateau c'est Maxime rock bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes responsable
communication d'Imagine fort Margon on
va parler de cette association dans un
instant puisque mercredi aura lieu une
chasse aux œufs un peu particulière de
chasse aux œufs solidaires à la Garde
Républicaine la caserne de la garde
républicaine installée à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ouvrir à ses
portes pour une chasse aux œufs on aura
l'occasion d'en parler dans un instant
on parlait d'Argentine qu'on va
justement rester dans le rétro ou dans
le rétro et on va rester dans les dans
les archives puisque on va parler des
Archives départementales qui viennent de
renforcer leur outil d'intégration de la
presse locale ancienne on le disait tout
à l'heure plus de 220 000 pages sont
accessibles en ligne couvrant les années
1819 à 1969 romain Dugat est avec nous
en plateau pour en parler vous êtes le
chef du service au public des Archives
départementales des Yvelines pourquoi
avoir voulu ce nouveau module de
recherche alors il faut dire que c'était
quelque chose de très attendu par nos
internautes
la presse locale en fait elle est
numérisée depuis 2009
nous avions à l'époque déjà initié en
fait ce qu'on appelle l'OCR c'est à dire
la reconnaissance optique de caractères
qui permet de faire des recherches plein
texte à partir d'un mot clé de recherche
toutes les occurrences dans les pages
numérisées et c'est vrai que le
désavantage d'être pionniers parfois
c'est que et elle est montée de versions
ont rendu l'outil obsolète d'accord et
donc nous avons profité d'un d'une
montée de version de notre site de
nouvelles fonctionnalités pour reprendre
ce chantier et donc re aux sériser si
j'ose dire l'ensemble de des titres déjà
présents en ligne et permettre cette
fonctionnalité de recherche alors
comment ça fonctionne très concrètement
est-ce qu'on fait une recherche par mots
clés par date le titre de parution alors
on peut faire un peu tout ça d'accord
c'est à dire que on conserve 250 titres
de presse locale ancienne comme vous
l'avez dit et parmi ces 250 titres sans
sont déjà une centaine sont déjà
numérisés et accessible en ligne ou
continuer à numériser les nouveaux les
nouveaux seront bénéficieront de cette
nouvelle possibilité
de recherche par
autorisation et actuellement on peut
donc chercher soit sur un titre soit sur
une année soit sur une période soit sur
un mot clé c'est-à-dire que si vous
tapez le nom de votre ancêtre par
exemple et bien vous allez retrouver
toutes les occurrences dans tous les
titres de presse actuellement
disponibles oui très concrètement un
simple mot va nous permettre de
retrouver exactement les choses
puisqu'en fait l'ensemble si vous voulez
nous avons c'est comme si on avait passé
en revue l'ensemble des mots contenus
dans tous les articles des titres de
presse qui sont actuellement disponibles
en ligne et donc tous ces mots sont
reconnus et le simple fait de les taper
dans le dans le champ dédié à la
recherche plein texte va vous permettre
de retrouver tous les articles contenant
ce mot par zone géographique aussi c'est
possible exactement c'est à dire que les
le nouvel outil permet aussi une
cartographie des résultats c'est à dire
que les les parfois pour certains titres
on a vraiment des publications très
locales au niveau d'un arrondissement au
niveau d'une commune et donc vous pouvez
faire afficher les titres de presse par
la ville qui vous intéresse c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez sélectionner une ville
voir le titre de presse qui ont été
publiés sur cette ville donc voilà on
peut croiser bien sûr aussi les les
choses c'est à dire que vous pouvez
saisir un mot saisir une période
chronologique saisir un lieu
géographique et ça va vous sélectionner
au fur et à mesure ça va filtrer vos
résultats pour trouver l'occurrence la
plus précise que vous souhaitez un peu
mixer tout ça pour arriver effectivement
à de bons résultats alors vous le disiez
ça concerne une centaine de titres la
période c'est 1819 à
1962 est-ce que c'est amené à évoluer et
ce qu'il y a d'autres titres qui
pourraient se rajouter alors on conserve
comme je l'ai dit 250 titres donc on
continue c'est à dire qu'en 2022 on a
ajouté 25 nouveaux titres en ligne il y
en a déjà deux cette année qui qui sont
prévus donc on continue à numériser
d'accord et puis nous des partenariats
avec des communes cette année avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les années
précédentes avec Versailles avec des
associations
l'association historique de Rambouillet
qui détiennent des collections de titres
de presse on fait l'inventaire en fait
des collections que nous conservons
parfois il y a des lacunes dans les dans
les périodes très anciennes il nous
manquait un numéro donc on conventionne
avec ces avec ses partenaires pour
numériser les titres qui nous manquent
et l'idée pour nous c'est d'avoir
vraiment une collection numérique de
référence on ne prend pas les bien sûr
les originaux qui restent dans les les
fonds de nos partenaires mais ça va
permettre à terme d'avoir la collection
de références de presse locale anciennes
sur l'ensemble du territoire de ce qui
était la sénéoise précédemment et pas
simplement les Yvelines puisque ça
dépasse globalement le territoire actuel
des Yvelines et donc tout cela facilité
vous disiez par des partenariats avec
différents organismes je sais qu'on a
fait tous les deux des études d'histoire
Michael et vous étiez déjà plongé dans
des archives pour des
exposés des mémoires peut-être après pas
forcément sur la presse locale donc je
trouve que c'est hyper intéressant et
juste une petite question est-ce que
vous allez faire ça peut-être à l'avenir
sur aussi des bon là j'ai compris que
c'était sur une période d'inventielle
mais sur des vidéos aussi ça serait
possible ou pas on peut tout à fait
après c'est un travail qui est différent
pense que
c'est pas le même technique c'est le
même technologie de reconnaissance mais
tout à fait après Lina doit faire un
système sans doute d'indexation aussi
pour pour reconnaître tout ça TV 78 etc
et certainement des choses à faire aussi
du côté des archives audiovisuels et le
but donc c'est de faciliter justement
l'accès à ces ressources aux yvelinois
au plus grand nombre tout à fait ça
permet puisque jusqu'à présent la
numérisation simple ne permet que de
consulter comme si vous consultiez les
originaux c'est-à-dire qu'il fallait
tourner les images une à une comme vous
tourneriez les pages papier des journaux
là c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui cherche
un événement son ancêtre
un mot clé qui fait une recherche je ne
sais pas par exemple prenons parler du
sport tout à l'heure nous avons
travaillé justement avec les étudiants
de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour qu'il
nous recherche des archives sur
l'histoire du sport
à travers la presse forcément si vous
pouvez si vous vous pouvez indiquer le
au vélo ou golf et que ça vous sort
toutes les occurrences dans tous les
articles ça facilite le travail que
d'avoir un dépouillement systématique
alors si je peux ajouter un petit mot
sur les nouveautés qui vont arriver
parce que ça c'est l'état actuel on est
en train de travailler justement aussi à
des notices partitres pour documenter à
la fois qui était le directeur faut
savoir que certains titres de presse à
l'époque du 19e était parfois très
éphémère c'était souvent un outil de
propagande qui soutenait une candidature
électorale et donc c'est aussi
intéressant de savoir quel était le
positionnement de tel était le journal
qui a été son son orientation politique
donc on travaille en fait à documenter
tout ça quel était le le
l'éditeur le rédacteur en chef
l'orientation le courant politique d'un
journal pour par exemple permettre aussi
des recherches sur on veut travailler
sur la presse légitimiste savoir quel
était les orientations favorites les
sujets favoris d'un type de presse on va
pouvoir le faire avec ce travail très
intéressant on pourrait en parler
pendant des heures on arrive à la fin de
l'entretien mais vous avez le droit de
petite question très rapide je voulais
juste savoir ce qu'il y a un fait
insolite qui vous a marqué dans dans ce
que vous avez pu voir il y a 1000 fait
insolites vous imaginez que à chaque
fois c'est la question piège quel est
l'archive les archives que vous
sélectionnerez parmi 32 km c'est
impossible pour moi de choisir il y en a
beaucoup que ce soit dans le domaine
sportif politique culturel enfin chacun
trouvera c'est justement l'intérêt de
cette indexation c'est que chacun pourra
trouver le l'événement la particularité
singulière qui qui le touche en tout cas
pour ceux que ça intéresse le site des
archives à retrouver bien sûr en bas de
l'écran on tape on va sur l'onglet
rechercher et puis presse locale
ancienne si on veut un peu plus
d'informations merci Romain d'être venu
en parler en plateau je le rappelle chef
du service au public aux archives
départementales des Yvelines et on va
parler à présent de Pâques hein vous le
savez c'est dans quelques jours et la
Garde Républicaine on le disait aussi il
y a un instant organise une chasse aux
œufs solidaires elle va ouvrir la
caserne de Saint-Germain-en-Laye ce
mercredi à l'association imagine fort
Margaux pour offrir un moment agréable à
des enfants atteints par un cancer on en
parle avec vous Maxime rock un
responsable communication d'Imagine
Formag fort-mardo précisons que le
cancer c'est la première cause de
mortalité par maladie chez les enfants
et les adolescents en France 2500
enfants sont atteints par un cancer
chaque année en France du coup
l'objectif d'une telle chasse aux œufs
c'est de leur permettre de s'échapper
pendant une après-midi de penser à autre
chose à d'autres sujets oui en fait
c'est exactement ça comme vous le disiez
il y a énormément d'enfants en fait qui
sont touchés chaque année du cancer
encore plus au niveau européen et en
fait le but c'est de leur offrir une
petite parenthèse dans dans leur dans
leur vie quotidienne contre la maladie
et grâce à la garde républicaine qui est
notre marraine depuis un jour notre
marraine de coeur oui c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle parce
qu'elle fait énormément de choses pour
les enfants on a la on a la chance
d'organiser ce bel événement qui est un
qui va être un moment rempli de sourire
on l'espère pour pour les enfants qui
vont avoir le droit une visite un peu un
peu particulière de la caserne c'est
important pour eux d'avoir ces
parenthèses vous liés parliez de
parenthèse pour eux mais aussi pour leur
famille oui ça en fait pour les deux
parce que souvent on pense aux enfants
on peut oublier de temps en temps un peu
les aidants mais les aidants sont
on va dire
on va dire le ciment en fait qui permet
un enfant de lutter contre la maladie et
ces moments de joie ces moments cette
parenthèse véritablement face à la
maladie sont sont des moments très
privilégiés pour eux et qui sont
extrêmement importants vous le disiez
marraine au grand cœur cette garde
républicaine de l'association imagine
form Margaux c'est à dire que tout au
long de l'année il y a des actions
menées grâce à ce partenariat justement
oui alors là en fait la Garde
Républicaine nous a rejoint il y a à peu
près un an on va arriver à la première
année d'anniversaire de de ce marinage
et en fait tout au long de l'année ils
font des actions donc ils vont faire des
actions ça va être des visites à
l'hôpital ou en fait les gardes vont
rendre visite aux enfants il peut y
avoir des concerts qui sont organisés
par la garde il peut y avoir des
représentations équestres qui sont
organisées par la garde pour les enfants
et ça permet véritablement de d'offrir
encore une fois une parenthèse la garde
va aussi se mobiliser lors d'autres
événements pour l'association dans des
opérations on va dire à la fois de
visibilité comme ça pu être le cas pour
la course en France en cancer qui a eu
lieu l'année dernière à Saint-Cloud et
qui aura lieu cette année le 24
septembre au domaine national de
Saint-Cloud ou la gare nous a fait
l'honneur d'ouvrir la course d'ouvrir
cette cette course qui permet chaque
année de collecter plus de 2 millions
d'euros pour la recherche et elle fait
aussi d'autres actions comme par exemple
dans quelques semaines voilà faire une
course à l'intérieur d'une de ces
casernes une course inter on va dire
intergarde ou les gardes vont courir
pendant 24 heures en continu dans la
caserne pour collecter des fonds contre
le cancer des enfants donc la prochaine
action c'est mercredi à la caserne de la
garde républicaine à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le problème de
l'après-midi beaucoup de chocolat au
rendez-vous on imagine beaucoup de
chocolats beaucoup de quelques activités
parce qu'il faut aller chercher les
chocolats faut c'est une vraie chasse
qui organisait qui organisé par la Garde
Républicaine chaque famille va avoir un
garde élève en fait qui va qui va les
accompagner et qui va les guider dans
cette dans cette caserne pour pour aller
trouver un panier de chocolat un panier
rempli de chocolat à la fin de à la fin
de la visite c'est les enfants sont
accompagnés par l'association oui oui on
accompagne en fait chez imagine formagon
on accompagne aujourd'hui près de 400
familles faut savoir que on est une
association qui a qui a trois axes
quatre missions importantes qui sont la
première qui sont accélérées la
recherche pour nous c'est fondamental
parce que sans accélérer la recherche
sans progrès en guérira pas plus et
mieux les enfants le deuxième c'est de
sensibiliser le troisième c'est de
mobiliser pour qu'un maximum de
personnes soit au courant du cancer des
enfants souvent donc on voit très très
bien le cancer mais on voit pas beaucoup
le cancer des enfants c'est à dire que
c'est un peu un sujet qui pourrait être
un peu tabou parce qu'on considère qu'un
enfant ne peut pas avoir un cancer et
malheureusement il y a des enfants qui
naissent avec des cancers il y a des
enfants qui ont un cancer tout tout au
long de leur croissance il y a pour vous
donner un chiffre tout à l'heure on
parlait de 2500 enfants il faut savoir
que sur ces 2500 enfants il y en a 50%
qui auront un cancer avant c'est ça
avant leur 5 ans et que si on prend un
chiffre global il y a un enfant sur 440
qui développera un cancer avant ces 15
ans donc malheureusement c'est une
maladie qui existe qu'on essaie de
guérir que on fait des on fait des gros
progrès depuis de nombreuses années
justement où il l'association a été
créée en 2011 on rappelle juste un
l'origine de l'association créé par les
parents de Margaux qui est décédé d'une
tumeur au cerveau à l'âge de 14 ans ils
ont d'ailleurs poursuivi son combat
puisque elle directement avait initié
une collecte pour justement aider la
recherche sur sa maladie l'objectif
c'est de collecter des dons je crois que
c'est 17 millions d'euros qui ont pu
être à louer à la recherche grâce à
imagine form Margaux il y a eu des
progrès notables depuis 2011 ou en 2011
il faut le dire on parlait beaucoup de
cancers pour adultes mais moins de
cancers pour enfants ce que vous dites
alors en fait en 2011 lorsque
Margot a été diagnostiqué Patricia
Olivier sont rendus qui sont rendus
compte que la recherche était
majoritairement axée sur l'adulte ce qui
est encore en quelque sorte un peu le
cas mais il y avait pas grand chose sur
l'enfant et en fait depuis 10 ans on
collecte des fonds on finance des
programmes on a financé près de 40 de
programmes au niveau européen d'accord
pour pour la recherche contre le cancer
des enfants qui ont abouti à 28 nouveaux
traitements 28 nouveaux traitement qui
bénéficie aujourd'hui à plus de 3000
enfants partout en Europe donc on a fait
des avancées après il reste encore il
reste encore du chemin à faire et on
espère pouvoir courir très vite vers un
monde avec des enfants sans cancer
dernière question comment on peut aider
l'association pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent alors pour pour aider
l'association c'est assez simple il vous
suffit de vous rendre sur le site
imagine form Margaux qui s'affiche alors
je sais pas exactement où il s'affiche
mais on va de l'écran
donc imagine form margot.org vous pouvez
soit faire un don soit vous mobilisez à
nos côtés parce qu'on a besoin de toutes
les personnes qui sont prêts à donner un
peu de leur temps c'est on se rend pas
compte mais c'est une richesse qui est
qui est très rare et on énormément
besoin ça peut être donc comme je vous
disais en faisant attention en faisant
un défi en partie pour nos événements en
faisant participant à la course en
France en cancer qui a lieu à
Saint-Cloud le 24 septembre prochain et
il y a sa petite sœur qui aura lieu
juste avant le premier juin à La Défense
donc n'hésitez pas vous vous connecter
juste sur enfance en cancer.org pour
point fr pardon pour la course imagine
form margot.org pour l'association et
vous trouverez toutes les informations
merci Maxime rock d'être venu sur ce
plateau on le rappelle responsable
communication de l'association imagine
formargo les résultats sportifs du
weekend c'est tout de suite dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et bien sûr Michael el midoro pour nous
parler de ses résultats sportifs dans
les Yvelines l'actualité était très
riche ce week-end on va commencer par le
rugby très belle victoire de Versailles
face aux ressource ce weekend et
Versailles ce sont imposés avec la
manière à domicile face une équipe du
Top 4 du classement il valide par la
même occasion leur place en phase
qualificative le résumé du match des
images de Céline Charles c'était l'un
des chocs du week-end en fédéral 2
Versailles installée dans le top 6
recevait le quatrième heureux sur sa
pelouse synthétique après une première
période équilibrée se sont finalement
les joueurs locaux qui sont devant à la
pause le score très à 8 pour les Bleus
et blanc les intentions de jeux
n'étaient pas là on voulait mettre
beaucoup de rythme on a voulu mettre
beaucoup de volume de jeu donc du coup
il y a eu quelques maladresses voilà
donc beaucoup de fautes demain qui nous
ont à chaque fois remis dans notre camp
donc c'est ça qui a créé un petit peu ce
déséquilibre en première mi-temps et qui
a chaque fois remis l'euro dans
l'avancée au retour des vestiaires
Versailles rectifie ses erreurs de la
première période et prend le large après
avoir inscrit plusieurs essais le club
Binois valide sa douzième victoire de la
saison score final 38 à 17 on avait à
cœur de faire un gros match le dernier à
domicile sur les la phase régulière donc
voilà il nous fallait gagner il nous
fallait gagner aussi avec le point de
bonus pour pouvoir prétendre à la
qualification donc c'était à un moment
important c'était un match quasiment de
phase finale pour nous donc l'objectif
est rempli les garçons ont mis beaucoup
de cœur on a fait vraiment un gros match
après cette victoire les objectifs des
versaillers sont remplis l'équipe et 6e
de la poule les joueurs de la cité
royale ont assuré leur qualification
pour les barrages à la base on était sur
un maintien et au fur et à mesure on
s'est dit qu'on allait chercher un peu
plus loin et là sur les deux trois
derniers mois on a dit bah pourquoi pas
le top 6 pour pouvoir aller au moins
chercher les phases finales et en tout
cas voilà c'est c'est ce qu'on a fait
prochain match pour Versailles le
dimanche 16 avril sur le terrain du
Havre le leader du championnat
l'occasion pour les joueurs de la cité
royale d'accrocher un nouvel adversaire
prestigieux à leur tableau de chasse
choisi fait aussi match nul sur le
terrain du chêné enfin Conflans de
s'impose contre le FC Mantois 2 à 0
classement où y est premier devant à
Bailly noisy et Marly-le-Roi le basket
Michael dans le championnat de National
3 trap 50 en Libye Renault avec la
victoire les Trappistes se sont imposés
sur leur parquet contre Rueil Athletic
Club le score 76 à 73 une victoire qui
fait du bien au cinquantinois ils sont
désormais à la 9e place du championnat
sur 14 avec un bilan de 11 victoires
pour 11 défaites un mot de basket
féminin chez les filles Le Chesnay
Versailles a perdu de justesse ce
week-end sur le terrain de Saint-Amand
Hainaut pourtant avant dernier du
championnat de National 2 le LCV 78
reste donc à la cinquième place avec 32
points engrangé depuis le début de la
saison on termine avec de la course à
pied ce samedi était organisé la diag 78
un trail avec quatre épreuves qui
traversaient le département des Yvelines
au programme à 100 km à 50 km à 20 et un
12 km avec l'arrivée unique à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines pour le 100 km
c'est lui que gentiane qui l'attend pour
qu'il l'a emporté en 7h44 minutes et 59
secondes avec une moyenne de 12,9 km par
heure avec près d'une demi-heure
d'avention le second l'écoute les
réactions au micro de Mathilde de Franco
c'est forcément dur enfin moi j'ai
optimisé mon potentiel ça c'est à dire
j'ai été chercher relativement loin
alors j'ai pas fait la bêtise de partir
trop vite donc j'ai pas souffert de
façon excessive mais quand même quand on
arrive au 60e kilomètre qu'il en reste
40 et on sait que ça va être dur et
effectivement c'est dur les très flattés
qui soient venus de savoir et pour pour
arracher cette victoire et puis
l'arracher de belles manières on a eu
des beaux compliments de sa part et
franchement c'est c'est la meilleure des
choses pour nous et pour toute l'équipe
on bravo Luc gentille pour cette
victoire sur la diag 78 on va continuer
de parler sport et de football américain
les Templiers d'Élancourt sont en
difficulté dans le championnat de 2e
division casque d'or après cinq journées
les élans courtois n'ont toujours pas
gagné un match cette saison à la moitié
du championnat on va parler de ces
résultats avec le nouveau président
Damien coquier bonsoir accompagné d'Alix
Wemba bonsoir coordinateur défense
comment expliquer déjà cette mauvaise
période traversée par les Templiers
d'Élancourt
simplement on va commencer par
recontextualiser j'étais déjà venu vous
voir d'ailleurs la dernière fois où
j'avais annoncé
une reconstruction donc qui dit
reconstruction pour partir du début
l'effectif qu'on a on le travaille mais
c'est un effectif jeune on a aussi des
nouveaux comme on l'avait déjà dit on a
eu beaucoup de départ des départs pour
de la première division surtout première
division ou là on a même actuellement un
joueur qui nous quitte qui va dans
l'équipe professionnelle de F Paris donc
on a quelques départs qui sont repassés
par des nouveaux donc c'est la
reconstruction c'est normal ça prend un
peu plus de temps donc il dit
reconstruction dit patience dis patience
et c'est une patience qui n'est pas
définie dans le temps en fait mais par
contre on doit s'y atteler ça c'est sûr
avec une difficulté vous le disiez c'est
que chaque saison alors c'est aussi la
réussite de la formation et
l'encourtoise il y a des joueurs qui
partent ailleurs en fait il y a des
joueurs qui partent ailleurs pour des
pour des nouveaux challenges ce qu'on
aimerait c'est qu'il reste avec nous
pour qu'on puisse continuer avec eux à
monter plus haut mais je pense que cette
reconstruction en fait comme vous avez
pu le comprendre ce que vous avez
présenté le nouveau président qui est
Damien ok comme vous avez pu comprendre
cette reconstruction à part de tout en
bas en fait on est en train de
reconstruire du début de repartir des
petites catégories et on remonte au
travail l'esprit Templiers on
retravaille ce qui nous a amené il y a
quelques années à des niveaux européens
où on était jusque dans le top 10
européen et ça c'est pas fait comme ça
ça a pris du temps l'ancien président
Jean-Jacques gotino à l'époque a
travaillé une vingtaine d'années pour y
arriver j'espère que ça mettra pas 20
ans mais en tout cas justement je
regarde Agostino est resté pendant des
décennies au Templiers d'Élancourt
est-ce que justement c'est un peu
peut-être bouleversé le club sur son
départ c'était hier je crois 4-5 ans à
peu près Damien ça joue aussi avec toute
une aire qui a tourné parce que l'air
genre jagostino c'est des joueurs comme
nous ou d'autres que nous on a formé et
d'autres plus anciens qui nous ont formé
donc c'était sa patte dans le club
effectivement puis ça passe sur le tissu
aussi c'est un continent donc forcément
le fait qu'il ait changé ça a eu un
impact club impact que on avait
peut-être pas forcément vu arriver au
mal anticiper en tant que que bénévole
du club mais on peut pas le lier
effectivement c'est difficile c'est
difficile
mais bon on a la chance d'être encore en
contact avec nous il est bienveillant
voilà il est venu on a eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec lui c'est ces dernières
semaines pour qu'il remette un peu son
ombre et puis qui nous soutiennent quoi
et comment vous abordez justement ce
mandat de Président vous êtes voilà
nouveau président du club dans cette
phase de reconstruction comme le disait
Alix bien sûr bah alors il y a plusieurs
points on va pas se mentir la situation
est compliquée moi avant d'être
Président je suis aussi coach de la
section senior donc on sait voilà on va
pas revenir sur le sportif c'est
complications d'aspects mais comme
disait Alix qui est bien c'est que sur
ce nouveau mandat et cette et ce nouveau
bureau on essaie quand même d'avoir un
bureau qui a l'expérience du foot et qui
connaît le foot et qui en crée aussi
dans la vie locale donc on est un bureau
complet
plus on va dire plus ouvert avec
d'autres fonctions le directeur sportif
on est plusieurs au bureau Alix aussi à
des fonctions indus bureau sur la
responsable des partenaires et des
opérations donc on essaie aussi de
s'ouvrir effectivement c'est compliqué
mais comme on dit en interne moi je note
pas noir on sait qu'on est entre
guillemets dans la
vague malheureusement mais on a un
projet tous communs qui part sur la
reconstruction sur déjà la pérennisation
un peu du club donc on va pérenniser nos
effectifs sur toutes les sections parce
qu'on veut éviter effectivement c'est un
peu la fuite des talents ce qui nous a
fait très très mal cette année sur
plusieurs sections on veut aussi
pérenniser notre notre bureau et nos
compétences au sein du bureau et après
ce qui va compter c'est l'étape d'après
c'est comment est-ce qu'on redéveloppe
toutes ces sections donc on a les
sections aux jeunes donc U17
U20 on a vraiment besoin de multiplier
par deux longues de joueurs et
d'adhérents qu'on a on a les sections
affiliées comme le flag qui sont des
sections mixtes qui sont des sections
potentiellement une catégorie
potentiellement olympique en 202 parce
que les JO 2028 sont des États-Unis et
c'est poussé on a les cheers aussi qui
ont leur championnats et dont on a envie
aussi de pousser vraiment de pousser le
développement c'est un projet global on
le comprend au retour du club exactement
et on a besoin de pousser tout ça sans
laisser aucune section sur le côté et
vraiment poussé parce que notre club
c'est plusieurs disciplines c'est
plusieurs sections on a besoin de tirer
tout le monde vers le haut de développer
ça et transformer en possède culture de
s'assurer qu'on a la culture Templiers
au sein de toutes ces
activités
parce qu'on sait que c'était un club un
peu
phare à l'époque en France et même en
Europe on disait tout à l'heure est-ce
que ça arrive toujours à attirer des des
nouveaux alors moi pour ma part attirer
oui forcément quand on parle de football
américain ça attire juste de par son nom
on ne connaît pas forcément donc on
cherche à se soigner par contre on va
dire que j'ai écouté votre émission de
la dernière fois et en écoutant un
extrait juste tout de suite et après je
vous laisse répondre effectivement nos
chroniqueurs de l'émission si on parie
sport que vous animez Michael on
débriefait votre saison et ils ont donné
leur avis on écoute et je vous laisse la
parole juste après
en regardant les réseaux sociaux ils se
disent que il y a une guéguerre dans le
club depuis deux ou trois ans qui se dit
donc il y a quand même quelque chose
quand même au niveau au niveau du club
quand même donc faut quand même se
tracasser parce que si derrière ça suit
pas les vins c'est ceux qui sont juste
derrière les seniors et c'est l'avenir
il y en a pas il déclare forfait en plus
il manque d'effectif aussi c'est surtout
ça c'est même pas un manque de commande
de commande de niveau du résultat c'est
manque d'effectif je pense que c'est là
qu'il faut se tracasser
vous en parliez justement et Philippe
disait des tensions en interne en tout
cas c'est ce qu'il avait vu sur les
réseaux sociaux bah c'est bien
d'annoncer des choses comme ça au hasard
c'est pas mal mais je dément pas je ne
confirme pas par contre ce que je dis
c'est que c'est clair depuis deux trois
ans
sur le site enfin le Facebook du club je
crois que les commentaires bon bah après
à un moment donné on peut faire tous une
interprétation comme on le souhaite
c'est clair que depuis mais plus que 3
ans depuis quelques années qu'on cherche
ce que le club cherche
en interne ça discute ça parle ça se
pose des questions il y a des fans il y
a des personnes qui supportent donc il y
avait peut-être des messages qui ont été
postés d'autres personnes qui ont
répondu je crois moi-même avoir répondu
et
pas de guéguerre personnelle je pense
mais par contre des changements comme
vous le voyez oui donc si c'est pour
annoncer un changement si c'est ce qu'il
pense que c'est guéguerre on annonce un
changement et en plus vous on vient la
Lancer chez vous en premier donc c'est
pas plus mal par contre il y avait un
autre extrait d'une personne juste après
ce monsieur qui a dit une chose qui est
vrai la jeunesse aujourd'hui on a un
beau public de consommateur et je pense
qu'il y a tous un peu tous les sports
parce que je suis très proche du club de
foot de Trappes parce que mon père est
fait partie des anciens là-bas et qui
m'expliquait pareil ce week-end il me
disait que voilà ils ont beaucoup de
consommateurs les gens sont un petit peu
moins investis dans l'esprit de
compétition et même quand il se disent
investi dans l'esprit de compétition
nous de parce qu'on a connu avant sur ce
sport là on sait qu'il manque peut-être
20 ou 30%
de de d'investissement et c'est à nous
d'aller chercher et c'est ça qu'on a du
mal à retrouver avec les jeunes
aujourd'hui mais on sait aussi rendu
compte qu'il fallait qu'on leur donne
cette envie depuis très jeune depuis
très très petit comme aujourd'hui on
était au collège de la clef Saint-Pierre
je vais passer le bonjour à Madame
Cardon aussi qui nous a accueilli et on
les voit très très jeune sur une classe
de 6e en 10 15 minutes on sent l'esprit
compétitif qui arrive rapidement et ben
ça c'est un petit peu perdu alors je
sais pas si les années covid qu'on a
passé ils ont beaucoup joué ils sont
pour quelque chose le fait de se
retrouver un peu en base clos et isolé
faire du sport personnel on voit
beaucoup de d'air de street workout où
vous trouvez des personnes qui vont
dehors faire du sport personnel
retrouver un peu ce sport collectif et
la dureté que demande aussi le
footballeur américain qui est assez
militarisé si on peut dire voilà ça va
être là où on va avoir un peu plus de
mal à fédérer mais par contre c'est
faisable puisque on a encore des joueurs
maintenant c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué en ce moment dernière la
question Quels sont les du coup les
objectifs de fin de saison quel est
aussi le moral quel est l'état du moral
des trous ainsi si je puis dire je
rappelle qu'il y a eu une récente
défaite assez lourde des fêtes face au
léopard de Rouen c'est le 25 mars du
coup comment ça va se passer là pour la
fin de saison bah la fin de saison nous
on est toujours à la recherche de là
même des premières des victoires parce
que on reste toujours compétitif on a on
a intérêt d'y aller donc c'est ça au
niveau du coaching ça en tout cas
l'équipe seniors c'est ça donc on fait
tout ce qu'il faut pour aller chercher
les victoires que ce soit sur les plans
d'entraînement l'organisation de
l'équipe etc pour revenir sur l'état
d'esprit bah forcément c'est difficile
quand enfin on a été joué aussi on sait
que les saisons comme ça c'est pas
facile après il y a quand même un
facteur qu'il faut pas oublier je pense
et je pense que de toute façon les
joueurs l'ont bien compris c'est que on
a un problème d'effectif cette année et
si je prends vraiment les l'exemple des
léopards où on se retrouve avec
presque pas assez de joueurs en défense
où on doit faire jouer des attaquants
qui est aussi le reflet de ce score qui
il joue pas leur position parce que pour
jouer donc c'est difficile mais
malheureusement
mais j'ai envie de dire heureusement
dans l'adversité les joueurs savent
qu'on est dans une fin difficile que
tout le monde donne du sien pour aller
en attaque en défense faire ce qu'il
veut donc c'est difficile mais on a
aussi en train entre guillemets de créer
ce groupe de souder les liens et on sait
que voilà quand on aura passé cette
période le groupe sera encore plus fort
et prêter d'autres challenges comment
dans l'adversité nickel où les poser une
ultime question je voulais juste vous
poser la question est-ce que vous pensez
quand même à la descente à une possible
descente Alix quand on voit que vous
êtes pour l'instant on va dernier
forcément est-ce que vous avez le
classement
mais si on s'arrête dessus en fait on
joue plus on ne joue plus nous on pense
qu'il reste 4 matchs il y a des
victoires à les récupérer des vecteurs
aller chercher et je pense qu'on se
posera la vraie question en fin de
saison je sais que dans les autres
poules il y a je crois qu'il y a eu un
forfait général il y a eu deux trois
choses on n'est pas sûr que des équipes
troisième division et les budgets ou les
possibilités de monter donc je pense que
c'est une question qu'on verra en fin
d'année pour le moment je sais que le
week-end qui arrive on doit jouer à
Bordeaux si on accroche un résultat
positif à bordé ça peut déjà nous mettre
très bien en fait ce sera le prochain
match effectivement samedi 8 avril sur
le terrain des Lions de Bordeaux on
espère une victoire pour les Templiers
d'Élancourt merci d'être passé en tout
cas sur ce plateau Alix et Damien pour
parler de ce moment difficile traversé
par votre club bientôt la fin du 7 8
avant de vous laisser les prévisions une
dernière fois météo de demain
[Musique]
du soleil et un ciel bien dégagé demain
au menu de votre journée dans les
Yvelines ça devrait se poursuivre
pendant une bonne partie de la semaine
le matin les températures sont fraîches
il fera 3 degrés dans le secteur de
Versailles et Mantes-la-Jolie deux
degrés vers Houdan et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi malgré le soleil le
thermomètre ne montera pas bien haut
elle comptait 10 degrés dans toute la
moitié nord des Yvelines 11 degrés à
Rambouillet ce mardi à 4 avril c'est la
Saint Isidore voilà c'est la fin de ce 7
8 merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dès demain pour une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]